Oh see ya
ah
boom a glory once brought light to the
world
driving the shadows away but it could
not last forever they whisper that the
end of days is upon us
the death of Emperor Theodosius his sons
divided our great empire as if it were a
plaything to be shared as Rome fades a
new seat of power at Constantinople
grows gold and silk flow through our
markets and our coffers swelled with new
tray
but the Visigoths have taken our
division as a portent of opportunity
and King Alaric marches on our border
with Dasia
to the east the sassanids motives are
clouded
our truce holds but any redeployment to
face Alaric will not go unnoticed
wisten umpires power wanes overwhelmed
by slavering barbarians from the north
he's now the time to amputate this
diseased limb could this be our
opportunity to reclaim the empire
the white horse a crown given to us and
we shall go out to conquer just as we
have done the thousand times before
in the name of
mighty dot
dear God forgive us